Hello,这是一轻有道机用,我不会闷斗的防晒和鸡
这五支防晒都是我,这有道机亲自是用一堆防晒当中选出来我
确定它不会闷斗,而且它们都是非日系的,所以你们可以放心用
我为了做这期视频,你们是个让我才能多少人
所以有道机宝宝在防晒方面,你们千万不要乱乱
防晒双真的是太容易闷斗了,其实我们很多道斗并不是说体内有什么原因,而是我们
就是一天防晒用上来跟闷出来的
这五支防晒的风感都做得非常好,两支平价的,两支桂价的,那其实没有很桂
然后一直在防晒吸塑的有色面双,那我先从平价的开始说吧
这个,一个很少状的孩子
我到现在也不知道我这个孩子要怎么念,是在装小货的跌里面买的
100多块钱真的很好用,是从入里防晒、SPS50片三个价
不知前面是需要摇一下,你们都听到我们,它里面是有一个刚猪的
但是它的刺底不是像安战晒那种涂战炎刺底,它是这种入战炎的刺底
鸿烤图云风感也很好,我会有命
上面它是会有一点点的分摆效果,但是一般或礼防晒都是这样子的
所以可以在素业的时候用它给我提一下气泽,但是这一款它是不会影响或许底装的发挥的
所以也是很跟装的
它这一支的场面名就是明感修无防晒无验,所以这一支也是很生命命机的
在这一支,其实我在上一期就有分享过它
我是真的觉得很好用,因为我这一期是想出飞日期的防晒
就真的好难找,很多好弄防晒都是日版
然后我找来找去发现这一支,真的是太好了
它是漂亮我身材的
新加比非常高,是我今天分享了无款防晒当中最成价的
是它的这个使用感有很棒,是这种
也是很轻爽的鸿烈之地
轻轻烈我就能抹云,SPR30
日常通情是完全没有问题的,上面没有颜色
后绝很跟装不错你,我们懂,不管是有动机还是有命机的爆爆,都是后
但是就是这一支千壁的鸿烈防晒,其实你们看一下它的这个实际
我觉得和他们家的这个摄影似的场面双非常地像,弄它
我用它的时候就觉得我真的在同一个非常轻爽的面双
这支我是在新加坡买的,它是SPR405 PS3个价的
在国内的话好像是SPR30 PS3个价
但我是了一下,他们的风感之地都是一模一样的
这一支官方,它也说是隔离以后去也是非常更装的
汤又完之后,会有一点单单的光红,跟我们看一下
这边是有光红的
所以这支如果是特别有的风试,我觉得就不太适合
我觉得就是等秋军天的时候再用它
但就是这一支我前之前应该还为它单独发过视频
所以就不说太多了,它的成分非常好防晒体系也很到位,
因为优秘都防了死死的
膚感好的就像一个坚滑一样
也很跟装是可以做装前谷的SPR50 PS4的价
你们如果对它改心就的话,就会去看一下这支视频
再就是这一支,这个是查理推荐给我的
它说它不会画装所以非常喜欢这一支,用起来没有反感
那我用起来也觉得它像是一个有防晒吸收的轻透环体验
SPR30制定也是这种粉底叶的制定
但是很好推开很好图云
我一般就是在少星,按一部了防晒一粗,然后再两张一粗
但是我会上散变,它的装感能是很轻透的,我觉得比很多专门的粉底也还要更轻透吸引
它有没有反感的,到乱上也不怎么按个散变
它好的点赞于我就算图量变散变它的装感也不会厚重
因为很多隔壁粉底叶,它们也都是有防晒吸收的
但是它们一图多了,就会感觉脸上的装膽很重
必须防晒又一定要图购量才能效果
这个我上三遍都觉得装感不错
看到粉感,但是防晒又够吗?
很适合平时早上时间比较感的上班组织
我最喜欢防晒加粉底,都够了
好了,这五次防晒都收完了,如果你们有喜欢的话,可以先去买小样,试一试,看看自己喜欢